a married couple near los angeles is in
jail accused of holding their 13
children captive in their home David and
Louise Turpin faced charges of torture
and child endangerment they're being
held on nine million dollars bail each
the couple's children range in age from
2 to 29 this this photo shows the family
in 2015 investigators say some of them
were found chained to their beds now
police say they were tipped off on
Sunday by a teenage daughter who escaped
from her parents and called police
David beg no is outside the home in
Paris California that's just south of
Riverside David this story still so hard
to believe good morning to you Gail good
morning Paris is a community of about
75,000 people roughly 60 miles east of
Los Angeles and this is the alleged
house of horrors
it appears well-kept from the outside
Internet records indicate there are four
bedrooms inside and we noticed four
vehicles in the driveway
look the parents of the male suspect
said they are shocked by the allegations
and more so they say that the mom and
dad who were arrested are deeply
religious people who reportedly felt
called by God to have so many children I
can't believe this I can't believe this
it's so sad
people living near the home of David and
Louise Turpin say they had no idea what
was allegedly happening behind closed
doors
many were even unaware that the couple
had 13 children living here seven of
them adults over the age of 18 the older
kids they I thought they were like 12
because they look so malnourished so
pale
neighbors tell CBS News the children
rarely ventured outside but on Sunday
morning police say a 17 year old girl
did leave or his authorities say she
escaped the young lady managed to escape
that residence and find a phone and call
the police to notify them that she and
her siblings have been held captive in
their home investigators found 12
children
several shackled to their beds with
chains and padlocks authorities say they
claimed to be starving and described the
surroundings as dark and foul-smelling
the youngest child is two years old
police say they initially thought all 13
were minors but were shocked to discover
seven of them were adults
the
oldest is 29 the six minors were
admitted to Riverside University
Hospital the adults are being treated
here at Corona Regional Medical Center
they're all in very stable condition and
they're all and they're doing very well
considering the magnitude of what what's
been described the children were home
schooled with the father listed in state
records as the principal of sand castle
day school located at the homes address
it's just crazy to think that something
like that can happen next door Robert
Gomez jr. has been a neighbor of the
terpenes for three years from his
perspective the Turpin home was messy
but quiet yeah I never knew that there
was any kids living in that house
especially not 13 the father of the
family who is the male suspect here
worked for Lockheed Martin but the
company says he left Lockheed back in
2010 now the family filed for bankruptcy
twice Nora that's about all we know we
expect to get more information later
this morning the police are holding a
news conference at about 10 a.m. local
time we will be there David thank you
it's such a sickening story to hear
what's happened in their stomach-turning
is exactly what it has